Bon ben...
À bientôt.
Rentres bien.
Toi aussi.
Et sinon toi, raconte avec cette fille hier soir.
Ah ouais c'était comment ça?
Putain les gars...
Cette fille, elles est juste...
*rires*
Ah ouais...
On s'est embrassés pendant des heures et elle...
...mouillais comme une ouf.
Pourtant vous savez
que je suis pas fan des doigts.
Et le matin, je lui ai apporté son petit déjeuner.
BAM sur la table!
Comme ça, sans prévenir,
il me chope par les cheveux le mec.
Il a la levrette...
...romantique.
Et c'est pas tout.
J'ai pris ma guitare.
Je l'ai regardé droit dans les yeux.
3... 4...
BAM BAM BAM !
Des claques sur le cul les meufs !
En parlant de cul je l'ai pris
en photo pendant qu'il dormait.
Vous allez m'en dire des nouvelles.
Oh putain il est gaulé!
Ah ouais!
Ohlala!
Ah oui. Ah oui oui oui.
Elle est super jolie.
Bof.
On a vécu un truc tellement fort,
mais fort fort fort...
...fort fort fort...
Elle est...gé...
...nial! Il est génial!
Mais tu sais tu dois avoir hâte de
le présenter à tes parents, c'est sûr!
Bon est niveau cul?
Oui nan mais j'avoue que déjà c'est sûr
à 100% que mon père il va le...
...suçait pendant des heures mon gars !
Voilà!
Je suis tellement fière de mon coup là.
T'as déjà parlé de moi à tes potes?
Ouais vite fait.
Tu sais je suis assez pudique moi comme nana.